Over the years that
I've been making videos,
I've visited quite a few strange
elevators and lifts.
And every time I do,
I get emails from
people in Germany,
saying "what about the one in
the New Town Hall in Hanover?"
And look, I don't want to become
'that weird elevator guy', but...
I finally made it.
- This New Town Hall is the only one
in the whole of Germany with a dome.
That's the first specialty,
and another one is, of course,
our curved elevator.
That's the only one in the world.
The elevator was opened in 1913,
at the same time as
this building was finished.
They didn't want to change the
design of this building,
otherwise they had
to install this elevator
just in the middle
of the main hall.
So they found one spot
on this building,
one small tower,
and the elevator follows the
form of the cupola.
It starts in the third floor
of this building,
42 meters high,
8.3 meters sideways.
This elevator technik
was developed
during the construction
of this building.
- Elevators were already fairly
common in high buildings
by the time this
was constructed,
but this elevator has a
unique design requirement.
It means to travel up
the side of a dome.
The whole elevator shaft is curved.
It's not a diagonal straight line
like the Eiffel Tower lifts.
The track bends as it goes up,
about 17°.
And it doesn't bend evenly.
It's not a smooth curve.
The path the elevator takes
is irregular and lumpy.
That would be a design challenge today,
let alone a century ago.
The new elevator was built by
the company Lutz from Hamburg.
You cannot use this elevator
the whole year,
because in the winter
it's very slippery
there on the dome.
So each spring, there are
many Hanover people
who cannot wait to see again
Hanover from above.
- The various parts and mechanisms
of the original lift
were replaced over the years,
and in 2007, what was left
was ripped out.
A few months later, this brand new
elevator was completed.
And it only just fits.
At points, there's only 5mm of clearance
between the cabin and the wall.
At other places, there's lots more.
Apparently, during testing
and construction,
it did bump and scrape
the walls sometimes.
Like I said, the path is lumpy.
Oh, and also, the floor panels
of this new lift?
They can be transparent.
Obvious question:
how do they keep the cabin
vertical as it goes up?
I assumed this would have
some kind of clever
self-levelling mechanism,
like a funicular railway, or the
tram at Gateway Arch in St Louis.
Or maybe a floor with
hydraulics in it,
so it would stay level
as the cabin moved around it.
But no. The solution is simple.
They don't keep the floor level!
The whole cabin is just
dragged up the side as one.
I can't lean on these doors,
but I want to.
I'm leaning on this pole.
We started out on the ground
at a slight angle,
passed through vertical
about halfway up,
and we ended up leaning
a little bit the other way.
Because a floor with a tilt
of a few degrees
isn't really a big problem
for a short journey.
So there you go. Germany,
you can stop emailing me.
I have finally taken a
trip on your elevator.
For a video about
an elevator ride,
that was a lot of steps.